do you think women can tell men how to
be men there's a
there's a
very loud group of uh
i don't know influencers media
personalities and all sort of thing that
that are constantly trying to tell men
how to be men and what a man really is
what are your thoughts on that
absolutely not
uh yeah women have no
business in that discussion whatsoever
men have always defined masculinity for
each other whether it's in a group or
you know in a larger society uh you know
men get to say what masculinity is uh
you know if you want women to be able to
say what femininity is men have to say
what masculinity is and and honestly
you know there's a separate set of
interests there obviously uh you know
when women define masculinity it's
whatever women want it to be it's not
what men need or what men you know know
about themselves
it's just what women want a man to be
and that could be anything from you know
you know shut up and do what i say
to
uh you know to the ones who want them to
be the strong alpha guy or whatever but
uh it's it's really about what they want
for men not uh what men are
yeah that's um
that's become painfully obvious because
i mean if you deal with a 20 year old
check her definition of masculinity is
different from a
40 year old chick that's got three kids
in tow and divorce right you know what
what she's going to define is going to
be the reliable guy with the minivan and
a good steady job and you know blah blah
blah whereas the 20 year old is like can
we go to ibiza this weekend on your
private jet and party you know
yeah
um
the
the book became a hit
have you figured out why like is there
like a secret sauce to why that book
became such a big hit with the uh guys
out there
well i think it was the right book at
the right time
and it was written
i think there's there are a lot of books
about masculinity and i still feel like
i have a lock on this uh to a certain
degree because we're seeing this again
now is that when men talk about
masculinity they talk about it in a
tribal way which is what men do
uh but they you know want to spin it in
their own direction you know like the
religious guys want to make masculinity
all about jesus or whatever and then
there's other guys who want to make it
about whatever they're about and i
really just tried to do my best like
masculinity isn't about i'm not the
exemplar of what masculinity is i just
want to understand what it is
and so
for all the different guys who are in
different walks of life i mean i have
special forces guys and guys who are
like day one week one uh maybe i should
you know do something masculine you know
like i have the whole gamut because they
can all relate to that
i think the strongest sound bite that
stood out for me in the book was the way
of men as a way of way of the gang can
you explain that a little bit more
sure yeah i mean i think that that's
again it comes to masculinity being
defined by other men uh and that's i
think one of the big innovations about
the the way of men is i looked about
like men select each other when you hear
uh you know
people talk about you know
evolutionary psychologists and so forth
they talk about masculinity and a lot of
times they were talking about it as if
we were like two elks fighting for
females or something like that and
that's not really
social animals
and uh you know to really be
you know to understand who you are as a
man you're in a group of other men
and that's our whole evolutionary
history is like groups of men
have to go hunt together they have to go
fight together they have to rely on each
other so they select each other i mean
the easy way you know talk about a
football team or whatever but men select
each other
and uh from that selection is what women
get to choose from so you know it's like
if men prove themselves to each other
they're already high status men and then
women can select from that
uh but i i think that this idea that
this gang is what actually defines mask
and i was being provocative obviously
like with using the word gang
uh but i mean that's really what it is
it's a group of men who all share the
same values and they're all going to
judge each other
and uh you know becoming a man means
being accepted by that group of men
whoever it is
yeah i've always said that men compete
in women's shoes and i think it's a lost
art and men have forgotten that they
have to compete and you know hold each
other accountable hey guys i really hope
that you enjoyed that short clip if you
did consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you